[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFF CLEARY: All right,
welcome everyone.
My name is Jeff Cleary.
And I want to give a quick
introduction to Sasha.
I wish I could say that I've
known Sasha since preschool.
But that's not quite true.
We met when our kids went
to the same preschool.
And I got to know Sasha first
as a great dad and friend
long before I came to learn that
he was, as my wife calls him,
a real-life superhero.
Sasha is the
founder and director
of RefugePoint, a
humanitarian organization that
finds lasting
solutions for refugees
in life-threatening situations.
He's also the
author of the book,
"From Crisis to
Calling" that he's here
today to tell us about.
When I read this book, I was
struck by how big of a story
this is and how desperate
the circumstances are
for the refugees in the Congo
and all around the world,
especially as compared
to my comparatively
safe and comfortable life.
But it would be a mistake
to only think of this
as someone else's story.
For one, we're all
guaranteed a certain number
of personal crises in life.
And there are lessons
from the book that
can serve as guideposts
for when we're
confronted by the
unexpected or the unfair.
And second, Sasha's work is
an inspiration for anyone
who wants to help
and do something
that's bigger than yourself.
SASHA CHANOFF: Hi, everybody.
Thank you so much for coming.
Jeff, thank you for
inviting me here
and for that lovely
introduction.
It is a real
pleasure to be here,
to be able to talk
about the book
that I coauthored with
my dad, David Chanoff,
"From Crisis to Calling."
Thanks to [INAUDIBLE] for being
here, Ryan, and everybody else.
Right now, there are
about 65 million people
displaced because of war
and conflict in the world.
And the average
amount of time someone
lives as a refugee
is nearing 20 years.
Congo is one of the places
that has been in conflict
for about 20 years now.
And many years ago, in
1998, when the conflict
re-emerged there,
the US government--
I think out of guilt over
not acting during the Rwandan
genocide-- engaged
the organization
that I was working for at
the time, the International
Organization for Migration,
to send small rescue
teams into the Congo
and evacuate people
from that country who
were being attacked.
And those people all
eventually came to the US
through our government's
resettlement program.
My boss, David, handed me
a list with 112 names on it
and sent me in on the
last rescue mission.
And he told me that, your goal
is to get these 112 people out.
They're in a safe,
protected center
with armed guards around it
near the capital of Congo.
You'll go in there.
You'll get them to the airport.
And you'll fly them out.
You'll need armed guards to do
this because Congo is at war,
and people who look
like Tutsis are
being attacked in the streets.
So you'll have to protect
them getting to the airport.
But we've managed to get
over 1,000 people out,
almost 1,500 people out.
And these are the last 112
that the Congolese government
has given us permission
to go and get.
And he said, I'm sending my
right-hand person in with you.
She's been on every
previous evacuation with me.
But she sometimes tries
to take additional people,
so you have to stop her.
So he put that
responsibility on me
to make sure that we only
got those 112 people out.
And then, when we got
into that safe haven,
we registered those 112 people.
But we were pointed to a tent.
And I remember stepping
into that tent.
And we saw all of these
32 widows and orphans
in that tent.
When Sheikha leaned over to
a little girl holding a doll
and said, what's
your doll's name,
and the doll's eyes popped
open, and all of a sudden,
we realized that it
was a tiny infant that
looked more dead than
alive, it was clear
the hardship and horror that
these people had gone through.
Mammy was a 15-year-old girl
in there who had watched many
of her relatives pass away in
the past year-and-a-half that
she'd been in prison
and in danger.
And she was one of the other
people in that safe haven.
So Sheikha and I left.
And she said, we
have to take them.
And I said, we can't.
And I tried to make
sure that I was
doing what my boss
wanted me to do
and what I had been
told I had to do.
But I wanted to take them.
And Sheikha finally said to
me, Sasha, we're humanitarians.
If we don't do
this, nobody will.
This decision is up to us.
And what she really did
was she connected me
with my own deepest
sense of who I felt I was
and what I wanted
to do, my own sense
of compassion and empathy.
And so we called our
boss and told him
that we wanted to
try to take them.
And he got very upset with us.
And he explained that
we would probably fail
and that everybody
would lose their lives.
But I said, I understand
this, when he said that.
And I said, we
have to try anyway.
So we managed, after
a lot of complexity,
to get everybody to the
airport with our armed guards
on the morning of
the last evacuation.
And then the Congolese
officials stopped us
from getting on the plane.
And my heart stopped.
And I thought, everything that
my boss, David, has warned
us about is coming true now.
But Sheikha went
over and started
talking to the head of
Congolese immigration.
And about a minute later, they
let us all board the plane.
And we flew out
to a refugee camp
in a neighboring
country, Cameroon.
And from there,
those people went
through the US
resettlement process
and then came to the US.
And I've watched them all
rebuild their lives here.
I've known Mammy now
for almost 20 years.
So that experience
opened my eyes
to people who are in the most
life-threatening situations
and off the radar.
Everywhere I went
working across Africa,
I found people who were
unseen and in danger.
When I went to
Kakuma Refugee Camp,
I worked with a group called
the Sudanese Lost Boys.
They have become kind of
famous here in the US.
There was a movie
called "The Good Lie"
that Warner Brothers did
with Reese Witherspoon
about their story.
And "60 Minutes" did
a piece about them.
But I saw that while all
these young children who
had survived horrors in
Sudan were all these boys
and young men were
coming to the US,
girls were overlooked
in that camp.
And everywhere I went, I saw
people who were overlooked.
I also saw that the US
Resettlement Program
is one of about 30
countries worldwide
that actively brings
refugees here.
And they have a
pathway to citizenship.
And this is one of the
three solutions for refugees
right now in the world.
Essentially, what happens
is when you flee your home,
you're either going
to go back home,
or you're going to stay in
the country to which you fled,
or you're going to resettle
to another country.
So those are the three
different options.
The problem is that people
don't go home anymore.
The average amount
of time, as I said,
is 20 years before
people return home.
The other problem is
that a lot of people
are just stuck in refugee camps
in neighboring countries, where
they get food year
after year after year.
But there is no hope for
anything better than that.
And so actually,
one of the reasons
we've heard so much about
the global refugee crisis
right now is because so
many Syrians and others
were trying to get into Europe.
And what happened there was that
the international community has
simply run out of
humanitarian aid money.
Food was cut off to
about 800,000 Syrians
about a year ago.
So people were faced
with the prospect
of watching their
children starve
and having no
access to education.
And they were forced into
dangerous onward journeys.
People are forced to
risk their lives to try
to get to someplace better.
So I saw that there could
be more opportunities
for resettlement and that there
could be more opportunities
to figure out how to help
people become self-reliant
if they can't resettle.
And that's why I started this
organization, RefugePoint.
So I started about 10 years ago.
And it was exciting because
I met a lot of people
just like you here
in this audience, who
are interested in
these issues, but maybe
didn't know a ton about them.
And I said, you know,
I know a lot of people
right now are in
life-threatening danger.
And if you can
support what I'm doing
starting this organization,
we can get them
to the US or Canada
or Australia,
where they can
rebuild their lives.
And for those
people who might be
able to stay in the
neighboring country,
we can try to help them
become self-reliant
there so that they
can stay there
and have a normal life there
and get their kids into school.
So RefugePoint now
is an organization
that looks for solutions
to refugee problems, which
is very different than the
whole international aid
community, which is primarily
focused on giving aid
year after year after year
with food and other services
while they wait for refugees
to be able to go home.
So what we want to do, and
what we've tried to do,
is help reshape how people
think about refugees.
They're not just victims.
They're people who
can contribute,
who, when they
have opportunities,
can actually support
themselves, contribute
to their communities.
And what I've found
personally is that they
inspire those who know them.
I have been incredibly
inspired by the people
I have met who have come through
the worst horror and hardship
and then go on to
rebuild their lives.
Mammy, whom you met, works
at a foundation in Phoenix,
where she's helping
other people.
And I've met so many refugees
who go on to contribute,
when they just have
an opportunity.
So RefugePoint is focused
on making sure that refugees
have opportunities.
And it's been really exciting
to build this organization
over the past 10 years.
But ever since that
experience in the Congo
that really changed how
I thought about my life
and what I wanted to
do-- so in the Congo,
I was communicating
with my parents.
I was worried that they would
be worried about me because this
was a new experience for me.
But it was also a new
experience for them
having a son who
was in a place where
there was a lot of danger.
And so my mom is from Finland.
And the Congolese government
actually had bugged our room
and was trying to listen
in on what we were doing
and understand more
about what we were doing.
And I was worried that they
had bugged my email too.
But I wanted to send
emails to my parents.
So I sent them some emails in
my mom's native language, which
is Finnish, which I
also learned growing up,
thinking that even if
they're bugging my emails,
they're not going read Finnish.
But from that point, I started
talking to my mom and dad
about this experience.
And I started talking
to my dad, specifically,
over many years about
what it meant to me.
And that led to thinking about
what critical decision points
can mean for other people.
And that led to this book.
So the book is
called "From Crisis
to Calling, Finding Your
Moral Center in the Toughest
Decisions."
And it uses the story
of this rescue operation
to talk about moral decision
points that people face.
But what I realized, and what
the publisher, Berrett-Koehler,
saw was that while my
situation was unique,
the fact is that we
will all be confronted
at one time or another with
some kind of decision that's
going to impact other
people in some way.
It might not be, obviously, as
specific and dramatic as what
I went through,
but that we're all
at times, either in our
families or in our work lives
or with what we're doing
or what we're seeing,
we might be confronted
with a decision that's
hard and might take us
out of our comfort zone.
But these kind of decision
points, I have seen
and others have seen, are
opportunities to actually
understand yourself more.
And they're
opportunities to move
in a direction of your
life that is more in line
with your own
sense of compassion
and your own sense of empathy.
And when you do that,
I think you connect
more with who you really are.
So in the book, we lay out
five ideas or principles
that help people to
think about this.
The first one is to be prepared,
to know that, at some point,
you're going to face some sort
of decision that might impact
other people in some way.
And know that that will happen.
And the second point
is to open your eyes.
Open your eyes to
what that decision is.
For me, opening my
eyes was actually
stepping into that tent.
When I stepped into that tent,
I saw those people face-to-face.
And when I saw
them face-to-face,
that was when it really struck
me that this is not just
about them.
It's about me and my decision.
So I think that it's
really easy to stay--
we're all busy in our lives.
Right?
Everyone here is-- yeah, I
mean, you're doing amazing--
a million things, and probably
multitasking all the time.
But we're busy with our work.
We're busy with our families.
We're busy with all
the things in our life.
It's easy to keep
your focus on that
and not look up and open your
eyes to some hard decision
that's around you.
The third principle
that we lay out
is to confront yourself, or
have somebody argue with you,
or understand what you're
looking at and think about it.
For me, even though I opened
my eyes to those people,
I still didn't want
to help them because I
had orders from my boss.
There was a lot at risk.
I knew that we were potentially
risking other people's lives.
I was really lucky to
have Sheikha there,
whom you saw in the
video and is just
this extraordinary human
being with incredible passion.
But she was the one
who argued with me.
And I realized that
having that confrontation
made me think about who I was.
My own family came
here to the US
as refugees 100 years ago
fleeing Anti-Semitism.
And I thought about my
great-grandmother, who
raised four kids on her own.
But arguing with Sheikha
helped me figure out who I was
and what I wanted to do.
So the fourth principle
is to know yourself.
Figure out what's in
your family background.
What experiences have you had?
What is your heart and
your sense of empathy
telling you what to do?
But even with all those things,
I was still really scared.
And so the fifth principle that
we lay out is to take courage.
I was really lucky,
again, because I
had this extraordinary
person with me.
But I would say, it
was a courageous thing
to try to decide to take them.
And Sheikha lead the
way on that because we
were going against our orders.
We'd been told not to do that.
And there was a lot of risk.
We had to double our armed guard
to try to get those people out
because Congo was at war,
and it was complicated.
But not all those principles
will necessarily come into play
with every decision.
But we find that
that's a good framework
to help think
about these things.
And we bring in a
lot of other stories
in the book about
other people who
have faced critical
decision points, people
from the military, people
who've worked in health care
and in many different
areas of life
to show that this is not a
unique situation, that this
is actually common to
face decision points.
But some of these
decision points
can actually help us
define who we are.
But the fact is that we have
a lot of different influences
in our lives that are
shaping us and telling
us to do different things.
And so there's this
great quote that we
found from the sociologist,
James Q. Wilson.
And it's about the sense of
empathy and the moral sense.
And the quote is that
"Humankind's moral sense is not
a strong beacon light.
It is rather a
small candle flame,
flickering and sputtering
in the strong winds
of power and passion,
greed and ideology.
But brought close to the heart
and cupped in one's hands,
it dispels the darkness
and warms the soul."
And so the book has
gotten some good attention
because I think that
it can help people
to think about decisions that
you might have in front of you,
or things that you want to
do which might orient you
in a way that will connect with
your own sense of compassion
and empathy, and that
those things are really
core human characteristics,
and that when we do that,
we feel more fulfilled
in our lives.
The guy who was Martin Luther
King, Jr.'s spiritual mentor it
is a guy named Benjamin Mays.
And he was also at
Morehouse College.
And he challenged his
students, saying, each of us
is born to do something unique.
What is it that you
were born to do?
And I think that confronting
hard decision points
is one way to try to help figure
out what we are each here,
uniquely suited to do because
I think everybody has things
to contribute to the world that
can improve the world in one
way or another.
And so I hope that this book,
"From Crisis to Calling"
can help in some way to shape
people and get people thinking
about the fact that we each
have unique contributions
to make in the world.
I also hope that it can
help shed light on the work
that I do and RefugePoint
does because right now,
more than ever, we have
an unprecedented crisis--
it's a human crisis-- of people
who are displaced in the world.
And we not only have to
think about how to respond
to that as individuals.
But I think right
now, we need to think
about how to respond
to that as a country
and as a global community.
So thank you so, so
much for being here.
It's such a pleasure.
And I want to pause or
stop there and invite
you to ask any questions
that you might want to ask.
I find the questions can help
to stimulate other thoughts
and discussion.
And there microphones
there if you're
interested in
asking any question.
Or you can just raise your
hand and ask from the audience,
and I can repeat it.
So thank you very, very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So I'm going to ask
the question that you probably
get asked a lot.
We're all sitting here in
a comfortable, safe place.
What can we do?
SASHA CHANOFF: What can you do?
Well, there's a lot of
different things you can do.
I mean, one is that
RefugePoint, this organization,
we actually have our country
director, Jacob from Kenya,
who oversees our
programs in Kenya.
And we have staff across Africa.
He's here.
He's sitting right over there.
But we have our
offices-- Jacob, welcome.
We have our offices in
Cambridge, really close to you,
in Central Square, and in Kenya.
And we have staff
right now across Africa
and starting to expand
across the world.
I mean, so one really
simple thing I think we've
talked a little about
potentially at the end of this
year, if there are opportunities
to give, to support
what RefugePoint does.
That's, I think, in terms of
if you want to contribute.
I think another thing is that
there's a lot of misinformation
right now about refugees
out there in the world.
I just wrote an Op Ed for
"Th Boston Globe," talking
about the US refugee
process and how
it's the most secure process
out of any immigration channel
of people coming to the US.
But I think if you want
to spread some information
on the internet or through
your own personal connections
about refugees and who
they are-- this morning,
I saw a great article
in "The New York
Times" about Syrian refugees
coming to the US and about,
actually, conservative
Republicans who
are reaching out to help them.
But regardless of your
political orientation,
when we come face-to-face.
with these issues,
they're human issues.
And that's a thing that
I think people really
overlook is that when
you come face-to-face.
with this, it's about
you and somebody else.
And in that face-to-face
interaction,
it feels to me like some sort
of moral responsibility to act.
But we don't all
have the opportunity
to come face-to-face
with people all the time.
So I think spreading
information, supporting us.
There are a lot of other
good organizations.
If people are really interested
in engaging and actually
volunteering, there
are some organizations
here in the Boston area
and also around the world
that help refugees
to integrate here.
And I got my start
working here in Boston
with the Jewish
Vocational Service
and the International
Rescue Committee, which
were two organizations at
that time in the 90s who
were actually helping
refugees to integrate here.
I hope that answers--
AUDIENCE: I have one specific
question just for this venue
and for this setting.
And again, not take
anything away from you just
said, which I think we should
all do, which is help out,
both with money and with effort.
But one thing is what we
actually do technically
for a living, which is
communication technology,
access, the fact that the
whole world, everybody can now
communicate with everybody.
Is there some way we
could focus some of that
to help out the problem?
Can you think of some ways
that we could use either
being able to
provide connectivity
or access to
information or access
to distance education
over technology?
Is there some
angle that we could
use to take some of the
stuff that Google is good at
and that we're all
good at technically
to help the problem?
SASHA CHANOFF: It's
a great question.
So there are some new online,
more global learning platforms.
There's a new effort
based out of Rwanda,
which started with an
organization and university
called Kepler that is trying
to democratize education
for refugees.
And it's higher
education for people who
are ready to study in college.
But that is certainly an
area of greatest need.
So President Obama,
in a couple of weeks,
is going to hold a refugee
summit in New York.
And at that refugee
summit, he's going to say,
among others, three things.
He's going to say that we
have to increase resettlement
globally so that more
refugees have opportunities
to get to countries where
they can rebuild their lives.
We have to expand education
opportunities because UNICEF
just came out with a report that
was mentioned in "The New York
Times" this morning
and yesterday how
there are 50
million kids who are
impacted by war and conflict.
And so many of these children
have their educations
cut short for years and years.
And that is morally impossible
as a global community
to look at and not
do something about.
And President Obama is
going to talk about the need
to increase work and
self-reliance opportunities
for a million refugees
around the world.
So what can you
do here at Google?
I need to think more about that.
But I think if there are ways
to connect in with education
opportunities that
are online, I think
if there are ways to
connect in with employment
and self-reliance opportunities
that are more online.
There are a lot of very
innovative, tech-oriented
solutions that are starting to
emerge that are intersecting
with refugees.
There is one right now that is
about helping refugee children.
And it's creating an
online platform to do that
and to make sure that there are
appropriate services available.
So I will get back with
maybe more specifics.
But I think that's
a great question.
And it's something
that, I think,
the whole Google community is
so interestingly and perhaps
uniquely poised to do
something to engage.
I know Google also has engaged
in different ways with refugees
over the past year
or two as well.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
SASHA CHANOFF: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: We'll continue
the conversation.
SASHA CHANOFF: Yeah.
Any other questions?
Well, great.
I will just say a couple
of closing words then.
First, thank you again, Jeff.
And thank you, Google,
for having me here.
It has been such a
pleasure to be here.
And I guess my primary thought,
again, that I wanted to share
is that we are facing an
unprecedented global crisis
with 65 million people
who have been displaced
by violence and conflict.
That's more than at
any point since we've
been counting in history.
And the average amount of
time that someone is a refugee
is close to 20 years.
So we need to think,
as a community,
about new ways of doing
things, not just giving
aid year after year
after year because
the international community has
run out of money to do that.
So how do we get
people to places
where they don't
need aid anymore
and they can become
contributors?
And we have such
a moral obligation
to do this for all those
people that are in danger,
but in particular,
for children who
are impacted by these
crises and just need
to have normal lives
with access to education
and other opportunities.
So thank you so
much for being here.
It's a real pleasure.
And thank you.
[APPLAUSE]